what's going on guys this is rob and the
eternals trailer just dropped this
morning now we have a reaction video
here on youtube
but we're gonna break the trailer down
in this video and i'm gonna blow your
mind
would you believe me if i told you that
we'll actually see thanos referenced in
this movie so here's the thing the
trailer initially opens
up with like this great big huge island
or or
land mass more or less and the people
look pretty primitive i would say this
is probably in the early days of the
eternals basically making their presence
known on earth it's kind of the on
running theme of the trailer they're
like they've been around for a long long
time and they seem to have had dealings
with people now here's the funny thing
about this right
i would imagine based on just what we
saw on the trailer we're gonna see time
skips with the eternals most likely in
the first
maybe 10 15 minutes of the movie to just
kind of establish
where the eternals have been throughout
the entirety of this time stream and i
believe there is a moment that we get to
see what happens when thanos shows up on
earth and how the eternals reacted to it
because i have an idea about this but
here's one of the big things rumors
abound about what's going on with the
eternal's origins in the marvel
cinematic universe
let me break it down like a fraction for
you guys with the eternals origins in
marvel comics and then what they're
going to do with the marvel cinematic
universe
and how the two of them are going to be
different so wind the clock back to 1976
with eternals vol 1 issue number one by
jack
kirby and the eternals are given to us
as a result of what's called celestial
modification meaning
that in marvel comics you have these
beings called the celestials that just
travel around the cosmos
and they experiment on groups of people
on different planets they came to earth
about 30
000 years before the modern day and they
took a small portion of humanity called
the wonders
and they experimented on their genes the
idea was that one third of this group
had their genes modified in such a way
so that they would have
unchecked mutations basically these
mutations would run rampant and we would
have no real idea what form the
mutations would take
or how they would look these became
known as deviants basically beings
who are pretty violent and just love to
tear stuff up the second group had their
genes modified so that at a future point
in time
powers would develop that's where you
get mutants from in marvel comics the
third group had their genes modified so
that they would basically have
these incredible powers they'd be able
to tap into what's called
cosmic energy those are the eternals the
eternals can basically do anything
shy of like altering reality on a
universal scale so to make this easy
there's no eternal out there that's on
par with thanos with the infinity
gauntlet if you guys want to learn more
about the eternals make sure you check
out my video at comics explained
the eternals explained and we also have
a video going out at the time that i'm
recording this video now
which is icarus of the eternals
explained having said that the marvel
cinematic universe seems to be doing a
completely different origin and this is
really largely just based on rumor and
conjecture but a lot of people are
freaking out because they're like why is
marvel changing the origin
and where in the world are they getting
this origin from see this is why it
benefits you to read comic books for 25
years the origin story the marvel
cinematic universe seems to be going
with is the origin story from earth
x which is a story that was written some
number of years ago but the idea behind
this
is that within that particular universe
celestials are born by virtue of
planting their seed
inside of a planet so the whole idea
behind this is that they plant their
seed in there that will eventually grow
into a celestial
when the celestial emerges the world's
destroyed in the process now if i'm a
betting man that's likely what's
happening in the eternals movie if i
really want to take my gamble one step
further i'll say it's probably teemu the
dreaming celestial the whole idea behind
this is that the eternals were created
to safeguard humanity from the deviants
and the deviants destroy things so more
or less the roles are kind of the same
the origin of the celestials are a
little bit different but the eternals
are more or less kind of like antibodies
now humans were given powers by the
celestials because
in the off chance that the eternals are
basically destroyed that humans would be
able to safeguard their world right so
humans and neutrons are more or less
antibodies that is the origin that i
imagine they're going with or supposedly
going with with the marvel cinematic
universe version of the team but i
wanted to get that out of the way
before we get into the rest of this
trailer breakdown because i felt like
that was important
so we've also got a couple of moments
here that i find to be really really
interesting the first one is angelina
jolie just kind of staring off at some
point beyond the camera and the second
is this guy who's more or less putting
together what initially looks like a
staff but looks like it's going to be
something more significant i think
that's going to be the in-movie
explanation of like where the eternals
come from and all that kind of stuff or
it's going to be the explanation of what
the eternals
really are because the marvel cinematic
universe is nothing if not consistent
and you can set your watch by a marvel
cinematic universe movie i promise you
can but the whole idea behind this is
probably going to get the whole
explanation of where the eternals come
from and that's going to be for us as
comic book movie viewers who don't
really know anything about the eternals
getting the whole exposition
but i think it would be interesting if
the eternals all this time have been
operating under one assumption with
regards to their origin and their origin
turns out to be something completely
different i feel like they'd be an
interesting caveat it would give more
dynamic to the characters
it would make them more intriguing and
more interesting because not even they
fully know what their story is because
what we're basically dealing with here
are essentially some pretty powerful
beings all of whom essentially dwarf the
power of virtually every single avenger
i would say with the exception of thor
and the incredible hulk but i guess it
really kind of depends on what story
you're referencing in marvel comics
after that you get a clip of cersei who
is kind of hanging around and watching
people do some stuff so i imagine that's
just the eternals kind of coming down
from on high their magical land in the
sky which is actually called olympia and
then in turn spending their time among
regular humans you also see what looks
like her putting her hand to the ground
and water just coming out of nowhere
that's cersei's power she has the
ability to transmute matter on the
atomic level kind of a fun fact about
all the different eternals
every single eternal more or less has
the same baseline abilities enhanced
strength super speed
all that kind of stuff most of the
eternals usually have a unique power
unto themselves ajax for example who's
played by selma hayek
has a healing factor that actually goes
beyond the healing factors of any of the
other eternals
cersei has the ability to transmute
matter and so that moment when you're
seeing her put her hand on the ground
and you're seeing water come out of
nowhere kind of irrigate the area
and then you see like plants and
different things like that growing
that's probably on that island so then
we get this moment when she says we've
helped them accomplish wonders where you
see this great big huge gigantic kingdom
looking place
that's most likely the result of the
eternals that's probably the end result
of when they originally showed up on the
island and you had essentially a very
primitive tribe and they more or less
helped them to learn irrigation and to
cultivate crops and to learn how to
survive
off the land and actually watch this
empire grow into this great big huge
giant kingdom that it currently exists
in at that point in the trailer anyway
or whatever that point happens to be in
the movie so here's a really interesting
thing that i noticed right we get this
moment where she says we never
interfere and my big question here is
why have they never interfered okay well
you can do it a couple different ways
but most likely it was a decree from the
celestials so
wind the clock back in marvel comics
again and you got something called
the third celestial host now the
celestial host just kind of a quick
explanation which i feel like i should
have done earlier in the video that's
what it's called when the celestials
show up to a particular location the
first celestial host was creating the
eternals the second celestial host was
punishing the deviants the third
celestial host
actually has nothing to do with the
eternals it's actually because of the
fact that when the celestials showed up
they found that like odin
and thor and like zeus and hercules and
like all these different godly beings
from other godly pantheons which we in
the comic book scene called sky fathers
had actually been meddling in the
affairs of mortal man right like
zeus had been showing up on earth and
banging girls odin had more or less been
doing the same thing but also like
instigating wars
and because of the fact that this had
the ability to to in effect change the
direction change the course of this
potential experiment
that these celestials were conducting
they basically gathered all the sky
fathers together and then said keep your
hands off
stay away from the humans the sky
fathers challenged them and the eternals
were just like
and like totally brought it into that i
mean like that like it was it wasn't
even a contest it wasn't even
it was just it was just total
eradication right the result of this is
that the sky fathers largely stayed
hands off
that's the marvel comics and comic book
explanation for why it is that like odin
and zeus and all those guys
had like all these stories where they
hung around with people all the time and
like they were
invested in like mankind all the time
and then suddenly stopped and that was
basically it
that more or less seems to be the case
here i mean i don't know if it
definitively is
it could just be one of these things
where the eternals just never really saw
a reason to act up until the events of
infinity war in avengers in-game but
whatever the reason happens to be i'm
leaning more towards the fact that it
was initially a decree from the
celestials which is don't involve
yourself in the affairs of mortal men
unless you have a very important reason
to do so and thanos showing up with the
infinity gauntlet blinking out half the
life in the universe and humanity more
or less being so inept they allow him to
is a pretty good reason to get involved
especially if you're
more or less a godly being we also get
this really cool moment where we get to
see this little blonde headed kid right
now this little blonde headed kid this
is a character by the name of
sprite and sprite is a little here's the
thing about sprite's character in marvel
comics right
so sprite is more or less the eternals
version of loki is really all he is
i don't know if we're really gonna get a
character like him from the comics and
the eternals film because i feel like
people would see that and they would be
like okay so he's basically loki i've
seen that before
do something different and unique marvel
there have been stories where sprite has
been a very serious character and kind
of the main ongoing arc of his character
is he's frustrated with the fact that
he's just eternally young
and he actually wants to grow up and
become an adult and that's one of the
reasons why he gets involved in
different escapades but to give you guys
perspective on some of the stuff this
guy's done
this dude wiped the memories of all the
eternals it's a little bit of a weird
bit of storytelling but you know
comic books we also get this moment
where you have three eternals who are
just kind of hovering in the air and
like the energy's passing between the
three of them that's the unimine
the question is how are they doing the
unimine because in marvel comics you
need seven eternals to pull off the
enemies it may only be that you need
three in the marvel cinematic universe
or it could be that all we're seeing
is the scene where like the first three
come together then the other four jump
in later on i have no real idea but the
unimine is a really cool concept it is a
source of power and a person who
basically possesses the unimined like
that energy source that kind of energy
gestalt is stupidly powerful but what's
the point of the unified okay so the
unimine is basically summoned by the
eternals when they kind of combine their
energies into a singular being and then
in turn
major decisions are made that's only
really the time that you see the unimine
come together
usually only really happens when they're
determining a prime eternal or a person
who is leading the eternals at the time
at one point it was thena who was played
by angelina jolie in the movie
and then she was challenged by icarus
and then icarus ultimately came out on
top right so icarus became the new prime
eternal but that's usually how the
unimine works
either that or it's like a major
catastrophe that requires the eternals
to come together in the form of the
unimined which really begs the question
why didn't they do that when thanos
showed up on earth with the infinity
gauntlet i don't really know but i think
we get our answer in the trailer
that brings us to two scenes that i find
to be very very interesting the first
one is
the one with thanos and of course when
they're kind of looking off in the
distance and you see those great big
huge thunder clouds and lightning coming
through and all that kind of cool stuff
i think that's when thanos's forces
arrive on the scene
i think that's when thanos shows up
right during the events of infinity war
and avengers in-game and i think that
the eternals stayed hands-off i think
the eternals were like
no we don't need to get involved like we
need to basically leave things alone and
i think the reason why is because maybe
they had too much faith in humanity's
abilities or
because humanity is the result of
celestial experimentation that what they
wanted to do was just
let the experiment run its course and
then in turn they could summon the
celestials when they basically believe
that the the experiment has reached
fruition why would they do that because
of marvel comics that was a whole idea
behind the eternals that the eternals
would stay hands off and they would
monitor the superpowered community and
when it was believed that the fruition
of the celestial's experiments
had basically been achieved they would
summon what was called the fourth
celestial host
and that's when the celestials would
show up on earth and then you would have
irishman the judge
an irishman the judge would look upon
the entirety of the planet and then
decide whether or not it should live or
it should die
if he judges against it the entire
planet gets cleansed if he judges in
favor of it the planet gets to continue
on and so as a result of that i imagine
that's probably what the celestials were
doing right just
let the experiment run its course and
come to a decision as to whether or not
we should just kind of allow
the whole of humanity to continue on and
the final scene that we get here and not
really the final one i guess the final
one that i want to talk about which i
really like is the whole dane whitman
cersei situation i love this idea that
dane whitman is basically this guy who
is in love with cersei right they're
kind of keeping that from the comics
that was a pretty important moment for
both of the characters but who's dane
whitman well
dane whitman is a guy who wields
something called the ebony blade and the
ebony blade is
literally a cursed blade so the way this
works is that that individual who is in
possession of the ebony blade goes by
the name black knight the person before
dane whitman
was sir percy of scandia also known as a
percival but this guy was basically
obsessed with battle
and that's what happens when you have
the ebony blade you become bloodlusted
as time goes on
you crave destruction because that's
what the sword wants now for dane
whitman it's a little more interesting
but we'll do a video on him over at
comics explained called
the black knight dane whitman explained
that reminds me thanos
i almost forgot about that so here's the
funny thing about thanos thanos is an
eternal
i'm sure you guys didn't know that but
thanos is he's an internal with a
deviant gene
so in marvel comics in the early days of
the eternals following their first civil
war
that those individuals who were defeated
were actually cast off of earth and into
space this basically led to them just
kind of floating around for a little
while and then ultimately settling on
saturn's moon titan following that it
was this really weird story arc was
something called the dragon of the moon
which incited them all
into civil war again but regardless of
how it happened that group that was cast
out of earth
ended up in a civil war on saturn's moon
titan and pretty much all of them were
eradicated except for one woman by the
name of suissa
ultimately another group of eternals
defected from earth and then took up
residence on saturn's moon titan
one of those guys was a man by the name
of alars alars and sui-san got together
touched naughty bits and they had a
couple kids
one of them was called eros the second
one was called thanos and as you guys
know thanos goes on to become
a villain so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring our breakdown to an
end i hope you guys enjoyed it make sure
you guys subscribe and we will catch you
all later
peace